mille couleurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france à leur nouvelle
mobilisation aujourd'hui contre le
racisme et les violences policières à
des participants la vue on en a entendu
un jérôme rodriguez pour que des idées
jaune
ah qu'est-ce que vous y voyez une
convergence des luttes pas de toute
manière oui parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
les policiers
c'est pas eux qui sont au fond du
problème c'est l'injustice dans notre
pays je vous rappelle que le manger
jaune est né de l'injustice parce qu'il
ya un certain laxisme à la fois au
niveau du social de l'économie de
l'injustice aussi et fiscale mais aussi
d'injustices quotidiennes dans la loi on
s'aperçoit que par exemple lorsqu'il ya
des violences policières ou des
violences contre les policiers
souvent les procureurs ou les juges
n'ont pas le temps faute de moyens ou
pour x raisons de pouvoir appliquer une
justice juste et complète visait tout le
monde et c'est ça qui crée des tensions
c'est ça le fond du problème plus que
des actions humaines qui aujourd'hui
font qu'il ya des rapports de force très
fort alors vous pointez du doigt les
injustices généralisée jean luc
mélenchon lui demandait en rendez vous
d'après midi une refonte de
l'institution policière justement pour
pourparlers pour pallier à ces à ces
violences et ce racisme dont on parle
depuis plusieurs jours est-ce que vous
rejoignez sa vision vous savez derrière
des gilets jaunes des pouliches il ya
des êtres humains et il ya des personnes
qui parfois commettre des erreurs ou
franchise des limites
il ya des lois il faut les appliquer le
problème en france et qu'on applique
plus les lois dire que quelqu'un qui
franc qui transgressent les lois dans la
violence se retrouvent parfois non
emprisonné voire non condamnées du tout
c'est sa leçon du problème lorsqu un
gilet jaune perd un oeil
le policier lui n'est pas poursuivie
quand un policier tabassé par des
manifestants parfois les manifestants
sont poursuivre ou ne le sont pas et
c'est ça le fond du problème du message
des policiers que j'ai retenu les
policiers se sont aussi des êtres
humains comme vous et moi ils ont fait
ils ont ils ont eu des ordres et les
vrais les vrais fautifs ce sont pas ceux
qui étaient sur le terrain mais ce sont
ceux qui ont donné les ordres justement
de taper sur les autres et qui ont
permis cette impunité et ce sont ceux là
qui doivent se retrouver devant les
juges et expliquer pourquoi il ya eu des
maltraitances et expliquer aussi
pourquoi des personnes se sont pas
retrouvés en prison alors qu'elle aurait
dû l'être de côté comme de l'autre nous
nous avons toujours qu'on est toutes les
violences
toutes ces exactions nous estimons qu'il
ya des lois nous sommes un état de droit
et que lorsque les lois ne sont pas
appliquées
et bien ce moment là il ya un problème
de justice et c'est sa leçon du problème
alors vous parliez à l'instant de
l'application de la loi justement ces
manifestations auxquelles on assiste
depuis quelques jours finalement elles
sont interdites dans le cadre de l'état
de crise sanitaire
quel est votre regard justement sur
cette situation est ce que ces
manifestations il fallait finalement les
autoriser mieux les encadrer ou et
finalement les interdire pour faire
respecter la loi
je pense que la vuleta sanitaires les
interdire c'est être excessif les
autoriser aussi je pense qu'il fallait
juste les encadrer et exiger un minimum
de conditions sanitaires
parce qu'on peut pas empêcher un peuple
de manifester la france souffre depuis
des années que les jets jaunes et les
problématiques avec les syndicats
maintenant il ya les policiers et une
crise économique terrible qui est en
train de s'abattre sur la france si on
enverra les premières conséquences
à partir d'octobre novembre à toutes ses
vagues de licenciements c'est précarité
où l'état aujourd'hui quel qu'il soit ne
pourra pas répondre à ce qui se passe et
donc empêcher les gens de pouvoir
exprimer leur colère qui d'ailleurs ne
l'expriment plus dans les urnes on le
voit lors des municipales les extraits
montrés peu profiter donc ça veut dire
qu une colère très profond c'est mettre
en danger nos institutions
il est temps à mon sens de repasser dans
les urnes au niveau législatif
il est temps de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale et de faire un gouvernement
d'union nationale
il est temps qu emmanuel macron soit un
grand président c'est à dire qu'il
arrête de faire la politique
politicienne mais qui rassemble tout le
monde autour d'une table et on remet
tout le système à plat et on remet de la
justice sociale et fiscale dans ce pays
là parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on est
dans une seule sur un baril de poudre
que la moindre étincelle peut mettre le
feu regardez ce qui se passe avec adama
traoré au delà même de les
problématiques de cette personne là ou
pas parce que je ne connais pas vraiment
les conditions judiciaires de ce qui
s'est passé dans sa famille parce qu'on
entend tout et son contraire
mais regardez ce qui se passe on sent
qu'elle la colère et que la moindre
étincelle peut mettre le feu et croyez
moi que la colère sera beaucoup plus
puissante à partir d'octobre novembre
est temps que le président à un public
n'ira pas dans le sens de dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale est de créer un
gouvernement de la nationale alors on
peut il prend le risque de casser nos
institutions et d'ouvrir la boîte
pandore institutionnelles et politiques
dans ce pays et on n'a vraiment pas
besoin de ça actuellement
alors c'est vrai que pendant confinement
on a beaucoup parlé de ce fameux monde
d'après ce monde d'après c'est un signe
aujourd'hui ce rassemblement
d'aujourd'hui il est un signe de cette
volonté d'une partie de la population
d'un monde d'après je pense qu'elle
surtout une volonté de redémarrer notre
pays dans un pays plus juste
ça fait 40 ans que la france décline ça
fait 40 ans qu'on est de plus en plus
pauvres regardez moi j'ai 44 ans je vois
les jeunes qui ont 24 ans qui ont le
même emploi que moi lorsque j'avais leur
âge ils gagnent entre 30 et 40% de mois
en moyenne et non pas de perspectives de
carrière la france n'a plus d'espoir
c'est un pays surendetté un pays qui est
mal dirigé des institutions qui
protègent les personnes qui sont en
place quel que soit leur couleur
politique
ce sont des élections qui sont toutes
les 5 tout les ans toutes les années il
ya des réformes à faire partout au
niveau économique
on a une monnaie beaucoup de crawford
dis pas qu'il faut sortir de l'euro
parce que ça serait catastrophique non
pas on pourrait le blesser à 0 80 $ ça
serait déjà bien
on n'a pas de puissance énergétique on
n'a pas de puissance militaire
enfin bref la france aujourd'hui en
plein déclin elle a raté ces quarante
dernières années le présent macron a été
élu pour tout remettre à plat et
redresser le pays il politique lui
prononcent pas
il prolonge la politique de ses
prédécesseurs donc on continue de
décliner et les français ne veulent
qu'une seule chose c'est repartir sur de
bonnes bases avec un monde plus juste
plus solidaire
alors pour revenir sur ces
rassemblements on a le souvenir
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
très musclé 1 lors de rassemblements
interdits au moment de la crise des
gilets jaunes aujourd'hui et lors des
derniers jours on a le sentiment que les
forces de l'ordre montre moins la force
justement en tous les cas pour le moment
la mobilisation est calme notre reporter
nous le disait est ce que vous partagez
ce constat et si oui comment vous
l'expliquez riez pas disons que les
policiers ont exécuté les ordres qu'on
leur a demandé
et qu'aujourd'hui certaines personnes
essayent tout simplement de donner des
ordres
un peu moins répressif parce qu'en
s'aperçoit que la tension est quand même
très très vive et mettre plus de
répression aujourd'hui ça serait mettre
de l'huile sur le feu maintenant les
policiers ce sont des fonctionnaires et
ce sont des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui connaissent aussi des
difficultés
dans les évolutions de carrière il ya
des problématiques parce qu'ils sont
soumis aussi à quelques pros
la tique on disait dans les banlieues où
vous allez dans les trafics on voit bien
qu'il ya des problématiques aussi qu'ils
de l'autre côté quand vous arrêter
quelqu'un tous les jours vous arrêter
des personnes et que vous les voyez
ressortir une fois deux fois trois fois
quatre fois cinq fois lorsque week et
des personnes qui sont condamnées 17 ou
20 fois et que vous leur envoyez dehors
c'est pas normal ça non plus donc plutôt
que d'opposer les policiers les gilet
jaune ou ce que nous avons toujours dit
c'est qu'on doit se rassembler pour
créer une force et permettre au pouvoir
de nous entendre et d'enfin régler le
problème de justice dans ce pays c'est
quand même pas compliqué de mettre
quelqu'un qui était qu'on a dit cette
fois quel qu'il soit de le mettre
définitivement en prison pour éviter
qu'ils en mettent les autres tout
simplement
et il faut arrêter de tomber dans ses
propos racistes ou tout ce qu'on veut
parce que les conditions de de tout ce
qui est violence et délinquance ça n'a
rien à voir avec une couleur de peau sa
avoir souvent déjà avec la pauvreté et
surtout le laxisme judiciaire cas dans
notre pays non pas à cause des hommes et
des femmes qui font mal leur travail
mais à cause d'un manque de moyens est
lui un manque de volonté politique
merci beaucoup david poulin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président du syndicat des
gilets jaunes constructif